la santé mentale vous souvenez on en
avait déjà parlé ici et on s'était
quitté là-dessus en attendant que les
séances et les psychologues soient
remboursés parce qu'il faudra bien que
ça arrive et le plus tôt sera le mieux
bon depuis à ce niveau là ça a un petit
peu bougé on va en reparler mais
clairement pas assez et comme la santé
mentale c'est hyper important vous le
savez aussi bien que moi j'ai décidé de
vous faire une série de vidéos sur le
sujet et ça commence aujourd'hui
maintenant
[Musique]
avant de commencer cette vidéo j'ai une
petite question pour vous est-ce que
vous saviez que ça existe les premiers
secours en santé mentale c'est comme les
premiers secours que vous connaissez
déjà sauf que au lieu d'apprendre à
secourir quelqu'un qui fait un malaise
cardiaque ou qui s'étouffe avec sa
bouffe on apprend à aider quelqu'un qui
est en souffrance psychologique et donc
il y a des formations pour apprendre à
devenir secouriste en santé mentale on
pourra en parler si vous voulez dites
moi dans les commentaires si ça vous
intéresse de toute façon je vous mets
des renseignements dans la description
donc allez voir bon ceci étant dit c'est
parti pour 8 bullshits sur la santé
mentale la santé mentale c'est
secondaire bah oui tant qu'on a la santé
santé sauf que la santé c'est pas juste
la santé physique là santé mentale elle
est aussi importante d'ailleurs de toute
façon les deux sont complètement liés
j'en avais déjà parlé dans une vidéo
donc être en bonne santé c'est être en
bonne santé physique et en bonne santé
mentale et on peut même rajouter la
santé sociale parce qu'elle est aussi
intimement liée aux deux autres on ne
peut pas être en bonne santé physique et
mentale si on souffre d'isolement social
ou de précarité on ne peut pas être en
bonne santé physique et sociale si on
est en mauvaise santé mentale vous avez
compris pour être en bonne santé il faut
que ces trois composantes soient bonnes
donc c'est au moins aussi important
d'aller consulter quand on a un coût de
pas bien psychologique que quand on a le
nez qui coule par exemple je le
répéterai jamais assez prenez votre
santé mentale au sérieux
la santé mentale ça me concerne pas moi
je suis bien dans ma tête donc alors non
non déjà la santé mentale c'est pas
juste le fait de ne pas avoir de
maladies mentale une bonne santé mentale
c'est une forme de bien-être
psychologique qui nous permet de vivre
bien et de faire ce qu'on a à faire et
ce qu'on a envie de faire donc déjà tu
peux être bien dans ta tête et faire
face à des difficultés quand même à un
moment ou un autre ensuite c'est très
large ça peut aller du petit coup de
déprime à la dépression ça peut être une
phobie des difficultés à s'organiser de
l'anxiété un burn-out une maladie
mentale chronique etc ça peut être mille
trucs ça peut arriver après un événement
particulier ou comme ça sans raison
apparente et pas besoin d'avoir des
antécédents ou une fragilité
psychologique ou je sais pas quoi ça
peut arriver absolument à tout le monde
sans qu'on s'y attendre même si on est
bien dans sa tête ce qui veut pas dire
grand chose d'ailleurs en France il y a
13 millions de personnes qui ont une
maladie mentale ça fait une personne sur
cinq et il y a une personne sur quatre
qui prend des médicaments comme les
antidépresseurs les politique etc si
vous voulez un autre chiffre le suicide
c'est la première cause de mortalité
chez les 15-35 ans et tout ça ça a
augmenté avec le covid donc pour être
clair on sera toutes et tous concernés
par un problème de santé mentale à un
moment ou un autre plus ou moins sévère
bien sûr mais tout le monde sera
concerné et si c'est pas à titre
personnel ce sera pour un proche la
santé mentale c'est juste une histoire
de volonté tu es triste arrête rien à
fout de ta dépression dire à quelqu'un
qui fait une dépression de se bouger
c'est à peu près aussi efficace que de
dire
me casser et est-ce que vous iriez dire
à quelqu'un qui a une tumeur
arrête ça c'est pour la dépression et on
va en reparler dans une prochaine vidéo
spécifique en attendant vous pouvez
retourner celle que j'ai déjà faite avec
Jean Massier mais pour le reste c'est
exactement la même chose quand on parle
de maladies mentale on parle de maladies
donc ni un truc qu'on a décidé d'avoir
ni un truc dont on peut décider de
guérir comme ça alors attention ça veut
pas dire qu'on peut rien faire
absolument et qu'il faut se résigner ça
se soigne mais
pas tout seul et c'est pas une question
de volonté les problèmes de santé
mentale ça soigne pas c'est à vie mais
si ça soigne je viens de le dire en fait
et puis non un problème de santé mentale
c'est pas forcément à vie il y a plein
de types de problèmes de santé mentale
il y en a qui peuvent se régler
rapidement disparaître et puis ne plus
jamais revenir et puis oui il y a des
maladies dont on guérit jamais
complètement mais on peut empêcher que
ça s'aggrave déjà et puis on peut
améliorer les choses pour mieux vivre
avec si on vous annonçait demain que
vous avez un diabète ou une maladie
cardiaque est-ce que vous refuseriez de
vous faire soigner parce que de toute
façon c'est à vie non bon bah pour la
santé mentale c'est pareil quand il y a
un problème ça soigne et pour ça faut
consulter point barre même si c'est pour
les fous alors déjà un fou moi je sais
pas ce que c'est mais de toute façon
vraiment c'est pas compliqué les
dentistes ça soigne les dents les
ophtalmos ça soigne les yeux les psy ça
soigne la tête il y a pas plus de honte
à se soigner quand on a un problème de
santé mentale que de se soigner quand on
a un problème physique donc que ce soit
des troubles anxieux une baisse de
morale ou un truc plus sérieux quand ça
va pas faut consulter point barre si je
vais chez le psy ça va être encore pire
ça va me faire remonter des trucs là à
la surface soit ça va me mettre mal soit
ça va me rendre fou carrément donc NON
NON MERCI
allez chez une psy ou chez un psy ça ne
réveille pas des maladies et si ça
soulève quelque chose qui vous fait du
mal c'est quelque chose que vous aviez
en vous de toute façon et qui serait
ressorti à un moment ou un autre donc il
vaut mieux faire ça bien avec une
professionnelle ou avec un professionnel
et le plus tôt c'est le mieux on va
faire une comparaison imaginez que vous
allez chez le dentiste et il vous trouve
une petite infection à une dent vous
vous aviez rien vu vous avez rien senti
ça faisait pas encore mal et pourtant
c'était déjà là le dentiste il va
soigner votre infection et sur le coup
c'est possible que ce soit plus ou moins
douloureux mais on est d'accord que
c'est pas une raison pour pas aller chez
le dentiste parce que ça évite que ça
s'aggrave là dedans et que ça finisse en
abcès ou enrage dedans et bah chez le
psy c'est pareil et puis la vérité c'est
que la plupart du temps ça fait pas du
mal d'aller aussi ça fait même plutôt du
bien ça soulage allez chez le psy c'est
cher bon là on va pas se mentir c'est
vrai et c'est pas normal il y a les
psychiatres qui sont remboursés par la
sécu alors pas complètement mais au
moins un petit peu mais clairement il y
en a pas assez pour suivre tout le monde
et de toute façon en général quand on
fait une psychothérapie on va plutôt
chez une ou chez un psychologue par
exemple jusqu'à avril 2022 c'était pas
du tout remboursé par la sécu et depuis
ils ont mis en place le dispositif mon
parcours psy qui permet d'avoir des
remboursements de 60 à 100% du prix des
séances selon les cas mais lui séances
maximum par an et des séances de 30
minutes seulement en plus il y a très
peu de psychologues qui sont inscrits
dans le dispositif parce que les
conditions sont difficilement
acceptables pour eux bref vous avez
compris il y a très peu de personnes qui
ont bénéficié de ce dispositif
finalement il y a aussi les CMP ça ça
existe depuis toujours mais centre
médico-psychologiques où on peut avoir
des consultations et un suivi
psychologique gratuit mais il y en a
tellement peu que l'attente pour avoir
un rendez-vous c'est énorme donc vous
voyez en terme de prise en charge c'est
pas encore ça loin de là mais je vous
mets quand même des infos importantes
dans la description de la vidéo il y a
aussi des centres d'aide téléphonique
vous verrez et sinon bah il faut payer
des consultations de sa poche et ça peut
coûter entre 40 et 100 euros voire plus
ça dépend où vous habitez à Paris par
exemple c'est plus cher c'est un budget
ça peut être compliqué pour certaines
personnes mais dans l'absolu ça vaut la
peine et il y a certains psy qui
adaptent leur tarifs en fonction de vos
revenus pour soigner un problème de
santé mentale faut prendre des
médicaments moi j'en veux pas alors non
on n'est pas obligé de prendre des
médicaments d'ailleurs les psychologues
peuvent pas en prescrire les séances
chez le psychanger des trucs dans son
quotidien etc ça peut suffire ça dépend
de ce qu'on a à la base et si il y a
besoin de médicaments ça peut très bien
être temporaire ça peut juste être pour
aller mieux pour être dans les bonnes
conditions pour suivre une thérapie par
exemple et s'arrêter après comme quand
vous avez une entorse et que vous prenez
des antidouleurs pour pouvoir aller
faire votre rééducation chez le kiné et
pour certaines maladies plus sévères oui
il y a des médicaments mais non prendre
des médicaments c'est pas automatique se
faire hospitaliser et puis surtout il y
a un truc qui s'appelle la prévention
vous faites plein de trucs tous les
jours pour rester en bonne santé
physique et bah vous pouvez faire aussi
plein de trucs au quotidien pour rester
en bonne santé mentale et ça on en
reparlera une prochaine fois bon il y a
encore plein de bullshit qui circulent
sur la santé mentale mais j'espère déjà
qu'on en démontant quelques-uns comme ça
ça vous a convaincu de l'importance d'en
prendre soin si il y a besoin et puis
surtout j'espère que ça a un petit peu
apaisé vos craintes sur la question sur
les psy les médicaments etc en tout cas
je vous ai mis plein d'infos importantes
dans la description de la vidéo
n'hésitez pas à aller jeter un oeil DTC
c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se
retrouve très vite ici et sur mes
réseaux sociaux d'ici là prenez soin de
votre santé mentale et de celle des
autres mettez-vous bien et surtout
portez-vous bien